hello I'm parenthetically Andrew heatman
you're watching mostly weekly and today
we're going to talk about patent trolls
they're like regular trolls only Balder
paler and prone to lawsuits patents are
the legal equivalent of dibs or a
temporary monopoly that the government
Awards to inventors so that after
they've developed a new technology
they're rewarded for their efforts
but patent trolls are gaming the system
to the point that the patent system is
holding back innovation instead of
encouraging it patent trolls buy or
register stupid or vague patents then
when someone invents something awesome
they claim the inventor is using their
patent and they sue that creates a
minefield where inventors are afraid to
create things for fear they'll step on a
patent and blow their legs off trolls
cost US firms twenty nine billion
dollars in lawsuits every year and the
threat of lawsuits strangles startups
and hampers innovation like this or this
it's good for Father's Day for this
that's a good Valentine's Day present or
this Christmas to be awarded a patent
and inventor is supposed to create a new
idea which is novel not just an obvious
improvement over an existing idea like
this the US Patent Office doesn't pick
every morons application so patent
trolls file broad vague and weak
applications that they can use as flimsy
pretenses to lob lawsuits of people for
example this is an actual patent that's
patented as thermal refreshening of a
bread product
oh you mean toast you can't patent
friggin toast for this method of
concealing partial baldness that's a
comb-over you didn't invent comb-overs
if you think toast and comb-overs are
overly broad you're right you score a
point
[Music]
which is also a patent Apple and Samsung
had a patent dispute over who owned
rectangles with rounded edges quit
fighting about quadrilaterals just build
me a robot Butler already four years
patent trolls filed their frivolous
lawsuits in East Texas
partly because East Texas was more
friendly to patent lawsuits and also
because it's irritating to have to fly
to East Texas
so defendants much like a substitute
teacher in her late 30s are inclined to
settle which is exactly what the trolls
want in the recent case of T C Heartland
versus Kraft Foods the Supreme Court
ruled that patent lawsuits must be filed
wherever the defendant is which is a big
blow to patent trolls meanwhile other
patent troll victims have started
fighting back personal audio LLC sued
Adam Carolla for podcasting which they
claimed to own the patent for rather
than ponying up extortion money Corolla
raised half a million dollars through
podcasting and threw in another 200,000
of his own to fight them in court we
don't know what the settlement was but I
imagine they didn't make very much money
and they'll probably think twice about
trying to extort the podcast community
again which means I can now fearless
Lehrer lease my podcast which is a
podcast about punks hey remember pogs
finally a guy named Alexander reeben
developed an algorithm that spits out
tens of thousands of invention ideas
every day if the troll patents something
in the future and sue someone the
defendant can point the millions and
millions of riebmann's ideas that
predate it and some of those ideas are
brilliant like a shoe tree for one shoe
and a pineapple Lily plant that can
track people that's innovation trolls
are on the run but there's one major
step we can take to hobble them what the
trolls fear most'
commitment obviously everyone knows that
but after that be shifting be shifting
means whoever loses the court case pays
for all of the legal fees it's what they
do in Canada and Britain although we
only do it for exceptional cases in the
United States if you knew you'd have to
pay yours and the defendants fees if you
lost a frivolous patent case you'd be
less likely to register it in the first
place on my end I'm going to file a
patent for
being an extortionist [ __ ] so I can
sue the pants off some patent trolls and
that'll show them how to and apparently
the patent for ironic patents has
already been patented so that's great
now if you'll excuse me I have a court
date but not for patent violations for
murder
[Music]